We've spoken frequently in this course about promises and the conditions under
which promises are and are not enforceable.
Indeed,
we usually think of contract laws primarily concerning promises.
Today we're going to talk about related but slightly different concerns that are
also integral to contract law.
These are representations and warranties.
What's a representation?
Representation,
concerns,
facts or circumstances related to propose transaction.
They are not the same as promises.
One helpful way to distinguish between the two is to remember that while
promises are forward looking,
representations generally involve past or present facts about the world.
Consider a potential agreement to sell a used car.
The seller's promise is that she will deliver the car.
She may make many factual representations about the car in the process.
She might say it is blue.
It has 50,000 miles on it.
It has a small dent on the rear door.
Those examples are all likely express representation.
The seller express Lee or explicitly and forms the buyer of those facts about
the car.
But just as we saw with promises,
representations can be either expressed or implied.
Most sellers implicitly represent,
for instance,
that they own the things they are selling and that those things are of
reasonable quality.
Moreover,
it's possible for explicit promises to throw off implicit representations.
When I promised to deliver a car,
I implicitly represent that I presently intend to perform that promise.
That's how the doctrine of promissory fraud as possible.
Conversely,
explicit representations can throw off implicit promises.
When I represent that my car was only driven to church on Sunday,
I implicitly promise or warrant that my representation is true.
Explicit promises or explicit representations can throw off a host of implicit
representations or promises and part of the task of being trained in contracts.
Law is being able to hear these implicit utterances.
We can think of warranties on the other hand as a special kind of promise,
a warranty promises that a person's representations are true.
Judge learned hand explained in a second circuit case from 1946 metropolitan
coal versus Howard,
that a warranty quote amounts to a promise to indemnify the promising for any
loss if the fact warranted proves untrue for obviously the promise or cannot
control what does it already in the past.
In other words,
if a representation proves false,
the party who made it has breached his or her warranty,
that all representations of fact are true.
The representation of fact in question.
However,
it must become a term of the contract in order for the warrantying party to be
liable in some then a warranty is made by one party to another about existing or
past facts that are knowable but not necessarily known and that become a term in
the contract.
Now,
sadly,
people use the word warranty at times is the synonym for a Ford looking promise.
Hyundai has a warranty that it's transmission will not break for a hundred
thousand miles.
One get tried to fit this warranty.
Talk into the traditional definition of learned hand and others saying that
Hyundai has represented that it's selling the type of car that has a
transmission that will last for a hundred thousand miles,
but it's easier to distinguish between warranties that promise that
representations are true and warranties that promise that goods will not break a
in specified ways in the future.
Okay.
Warranties are very important because they allocate risk.
The party who makes a representation bears the risk that the representation made
will prove quote not in accord with the facts unquote.
How does this allocation of risks compare to the mistake doctrines we've earlier
discussed?
Well,
mistake doctrines tend to let sellers out of contracts where there are basic
mistakes that increased the value of the thing traded.
Think of Sherwood v versus walkers and the mistake doctrines let buyers out of
contracts where there are basic mistakes that decrease the value of the thing
traded.
Think of the Lenawee case,
that is your lead out the buyer or the seller,
unless a contract allocates the risk and to the other side,
a seller making a representation is one of the ways that the parties can
allocate a risk to the seller or to the buyer.
Okay.
Warranties unsurprisingly can also be express or implied.
The UCC section two three 13 establishes three ways sellers of goods can create
express warranties.
First,
any affirmation of fact the seller makes that relates to the goods being sold
and becomes part of the basis of the bargain,
creates an express warranty that the goods will conform to that affirmation.
Second,
any description of the goods that becomes part of the basis of the bargain
creates an express warranty that the goods will conform to that description.
And third,
any sample or a model of the goods which is made part of the basis of the
bargain creates an express warranty that the whole of the goods will conform to
the sample or to the model.
The UCC emphasizes further that sellers do not have to specifically intend to
make a warranty or need use or need use words like warranty or guarantee in
order to create an express warranty.
Indeed,
because any agreement must involve some minimum description of the goods being
transacted in,
in order to be specific enough to be enforceable.
Every contract will necessarily entail some express warranty.
If you're trying to have a contract to buy a bicycle,
it's very hard to have it,
uh,
not make at least a description that what is being purchased is a bicycle.
But the UCC section two,
three 13 also specifies certain statements that don't create express warranties,
affirmations of the value of the goods or statements that only purport to be the
seller's opinion or commendation of the goods.
These statements regarding opinion or commendation or an effect just puffing,
but I find it annoyingly ambiguous that the UCC provision says that quote,
an affirmation merely of the value of the goods unquote does not create an
express warranty and affirmation about the value of the goods to my mind is not
mere.
It seems to go to the central basis of the bargain.
If the seller says that a baseball card has a market value of $45 that should
create an express warranty because market value is falsifiable.
Even saying that a baseball card has a value of $45 should to my mind,
create an express warranty that would be violated if the market value is
substantially lower.
Saying that a painting has a high value,
on the other hand might be mere puffing.
The section doesn't distinguish between these different scenarios.
Luckily,
comment eight to the section says that with regard to false statements of value
quote,
the possibility is left open that a remedy may be provided by the law relating
to fraud or misrepresentation.
The UCC also establishes in three separate provisions,
three important implied or default warranties.
The first of these,
section two three 12 is the implied warranty of title,
which applies to all sales.
The second of these two three 14 is the implied warranty of merchantability
which applies only to merchants.
This provision states that in a contract for the sale of goods the seller as if
a merchant impliedly
warrants those goods will be merchantable with respect to the goods of that
kind.
The core meaning of merchantability is basically that the goods are fit for the
ordinary purposes for which such goods are used.
The third of these default warranties is section two three 15 and it's the
implied warranty of fitness for a particular purpose.
This comes up with buyers who disclose that they need goods for our particular
purpose.
That particular purpose is distinct from the ordinary purpose we just mentioned.
With respect to merchantability,
it concerns a specific use by the buyer that is peculiar to the nature of the
buyer's business or use of the goods and not just the ordinary use of the goods.
Section two three 15 explains that there is an implied warranty.
The goods will be fit for that particular purpose where the seller at the time
of contracting has reason to know any particular purpose for which the goods are
required and that buyer is relying on the seller's skill or judgment to select
or furnish suitable goods to three 15 is another circumstance we're making a
representation may impose duties on the other contractor.
We already discussed how making a representation may create a duty on the other
contractor to correct your mistake but with section two three 15 making a
representation as to why you require a good can create a duty on skilled sellers
at least to provide goods that conform to that requirement.
These three provisions are default rules.
Parties can contract around them if they wish,
but the UCC in section two three 16 also lays out altering rules.
The second order legal rules regulating the ways in which parties can disclaim
or limit the warranties or remedies for breach of these warranties.
Subsection two for instance,
says that in order to exclude or modified the implied warranty of
merchantability,
the contractual language must mention merchantability.
And in the case of a writing,
it must be a conspicuous statement.
Similarly to exclude or modified the implied warranty of fitness for a
particular purpose.
The exclusion must be a writing and be conspicuous.
But subsection two is subject to set to subsection three which states more
broadly that all implied warranties can be excluded by expressions such as,
as is or with all faults or other language which in common understanding calls
the buyer's attention to the exclusion of warranties and makes plain that there
is no implied warranty.
So even subsection two says that waiver of the warranty of merchantability must
mention merchantability subsection three says mentioned that such mentions of
merchant ability are not necessary if the contract includes as is or a similar,
uh,
waiver language further and in and importantly,
the UCC denies buyer's protection of implied warranties.
If goods have defects about which the buyer knew or should have known quote when
the buyer before entering into the contract has examined the goods or the sample
or model as fully as he desired or has refused to examine the goods.
There is no implied warranty with regard to defects which an examination art in
the circumstances to have revealed to him.
You probably noticed warranty provisions in the agreements for purchases you've
made for hard goods like your computer or smartphone.
These clauses and become quite standard across the various industries that they,
these clauses generally disclaim implied warranties and expressly warrant the
goods against defects in material and workmanship.
Further,
they usually limit the remedies for breach of the warranties to just repairing
or replacing the product.
That is that they promised to either repair the defective good or replace the
defective parts and also they,
these provisions tend to set a limit on the amount of time in which claims under
the warranties can be made and they exclude liability for a contractual damages.
But the capacity of companies to contract around liability in this manner is at
least a little circumscribed.
Imagine you purchase a product that uh,
uh,
it becomes defective and after several attempts by the manufacturer to repair or
replace,
the product still doesn't work even though the agreement for the product states
that your remedies are limited to repair or replacement of defective parts,
the UCC section two 719 provides that when a remedy quote fails,
if it's essential purpose unquote a buyer may seek damages for the defective
product using the default,
uh,
remedies of the UCC.
So if you attempt attempt to repair and replacement time and time again and it
continues to fail to put the product back into working condition,
you might be able to recover full UCC damages.
So what have we learned?
We've learned about the important role of representations of fact and contract
law and we won't forget that representations of fact are distinct from promises.
We've learned that representation and contracts throw off implied warranties and
that because all contracts must contain some representations,
all contracts entail some kinds of at least implied warranties.
We've learned these warranties allocate risk to the representing party,
and so sellers can be liable when their representations turned out to be false.
We talked about the express warranties and implied warranties that the UCC sets
out and about.
The UCC is altering rules,
the provisions that limit the ways to contract around those default rules.